[ Scanner buzzing ]
[ Computer hums ]
These are invalid.
You girls gotta move along.
Wait, wait, wait. Are --
I got them on Craigslist.
So just, like --
[ Laughing ] Did you
just say Craigslist?
Girls ain't never heard
of StubHub?
These are for sure fake.
Get out of my line.
Go.
And how old
are y'all anyway?
I can't tell, 'cause the outfits
aren't matching the faces.
Next?
I'm sorry, dude.
I'm a [bleep] idiot.
No, you are not. Craigslist is
the most legitimate business,
okay?
The last time we used it,
we cleaned that dude's apartment
in our underwear.
I see.
[ Chuckles ]
[ Muffled hip-hop music playing,
crowd cheering ]
Okay, okay, okay.
I bet -- No, I know
that we can find
some silly-ass way in here.
Okay.
Okay, we gotta do this
before the Molly kicks in.
Yeah.
[ Chuckles ]
♪♪
God, I'm feeling something,
you know?
It is upon us.
[ Chuckles ]
♪♪
Abbi! Come. Now. Come.
-What? What?
-♪ Look at the vent ♪
Okay. We get up there.
If we can,
we crawl inside. We sneak
inside the venue. We're done.
Oh, my God. Dude.
I have a Swiss Army knife.
It can unscrew
the screws!
Okay. I know exactly
how we get up there.
You get on my shoulders.
You do the thing.
You pry it open.
You crawl inside.
Oh, my gosh. Once I'm inside,
I'll, like, take my clothes off,
and I'll, like, tie 'em
all in a rope, okay, in a knot.
And I'll pull you up.
I'm actually getting hot anyway,
so this works out.
Yas, bitch!
This is fully happening!
-We are such a team.
-Incredible.
-All right, so --
-Maybe like that, okay?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, put one arm.
You know, what if we,
like, use the wall --
Yeah, yeah, yeah. If my back
pushes up against the wall --
-Against the wall.
-Yeah, yeah.
-And then we'll go --
-Yeah, right this way.
[ Gasps ]
-Ladders!
Abbi, this is so beautiful!
Dude, you ever think about
how many lil's there are
besides Wayne?
Lil' Kim, Lil' Yachty,
Lil' Dicky, Lil' Dookie,
Lil' Rel, Lil' Deval, Lil' Papa,
Lil' Mama, Lil' Uzi Vert --
Wait, wait, wait. Vert,
like a -- Like a string bean?
Like a -- the legume?
No, no, no. That's...
[French accent] Haricot Vert.
Oh, my God.
If I was a rapper,
my name would be
Les Petites Haricot Vert.
Oh, my God!
I'd be Lil' Webding!
Oh, my God. I'd be -- I'd be
Lil' -- Lil Two-ply.
-Lil' Clit Stem.
-Oh, my God.
I'd be Lil' Nap Time?
[ Both laugh ]
Lil' Mammogram
to advertise the importance
-of getting mammograms.
-Oh!
Okay, dude, should we
go down here?
Oh, yeah, yeah.
Maybe let's try.
[ Air blowing ]
[ Both screaming ]
Oh, my God. Dude.
The "litter" stayed light!
[ Shrieking ]
The litter stayed light.
Oh, my God.
Whispering is so dope.
-I forgot.
-Yes.
[ Muffled music playing ]
Oh, my God.
Do you hear him?
I forgot we were at
a Lil Wayne concert!
Me, too!
Oh, my goodness.
But, like,
he -- he sounds
different, right?
Yeah. Yeah,
it's like, I love
how I don't necessarily love it,
you know what I mean?
But I'm an unconditional
ride-or-die for him,
and I'm grateful for what
we went through to get here!
Me, too. Me, too.
Oh, my God. Dude.
Oh, my goodness.
-No! What?! Please!
-I have such a good idea.
Dude, gotta try
to reposition.
-Okay.
-Yeah, okay.
It's sounds --
It's sounds like we're, like,
right above the audience, right?
Right.
-Okay. What if we dropped down?
-No.
Dude, what if we dropped
down? There's gotta
be, like, a door down.
We drop down
onto the audience.
-Dude, or --
-Break some skulls, dude!
Or the stage.
Like, we drop down
onto the stage,
and we're, like,
part of it.
Okay, yes.
-Right.
-Fully [bleep] yes.
-Yeah.
-Or...
we could go back
to the alley
that we were hanging at,
and just not be
inside a vent?
Yeah. Yeah.
We got our own
Lil' Weezy concert
right...here.
Yes, dude!
[ Lil Wayne's
"A Milli" playing ]
♪♪
Dude, can I tell you
something?
Anything.
You can tell me anything, dude.
I don't know if I know
who I am without you.
I don't have the same sense
of self I thought I did.
Dude, I am terrified.
I'm like, "Do I even, like,
know how to make new friends?"
I'm like do I like people, even?
I don't even know, you know?
Well, see, that's
my damn problem, dawg.
I worry in retrospect that
I've been co-opting your time
and keeping you from growing,
-you know what I mean?
-No, dude.
I feel like I've been relying
on you for like, my confidence.
Like, I didn't even know
my ass was dope
until you taught me it was.
It's like,
you don't just, like, keep
bringing people fish, you know?
You teach them
how to use their ass.
And then they never go hungry,
you know what I mean?
They never go hungry.
Oof, dat...ass, though.
Damn, girl!
Shit, bitch!
You know, like,
I need to make, like,
meaning of my own,
you know, as an individual,
rather than peg --
-LOL -- Remember Jeremy?
-Yes!
Everything on the entity
that is us.
I wanna be, like, in
a relationship like we have,
but someone who
I have sex with, you know,
and, like, I cuddle with
and shit.
Tell me about it!
You know, I realize now
that I didn't give Lincoln
really a full, true,
and real shot 'cause
I always made you my priority.
And you know what?
Now that I think about it,
these nosebleeds
that I keep getting,
it's every time
I think of us apart,
so it's really like
a psychosomatic response
to our crippling
co-dependency.
[ Both laugh ]
I mean, maybe.
I don't know.
Dude! Oh, my God. Dude.
We are co-dependent!
We, you, me, we're
Lil' Codies, dude!
That's our DJ name.
Oh, my God. Dude.
Yas, Cody!
Go, Cody!
[ Both laugh ]
You know, and this space
is gonna give us the chance
to be our better,
bolder selves.
-Boulder!
-[ Gasps ]
-Oh! Boulder!
-Boulder!
[ Both laugh ]
♪♪
[ Sighs ]
It sucks.
But also, it doesn't.
It's gonna be great.
♪♪
Yeah, dude.
It's gonna be great.
It's gonna be, like, so good.
We're gonna make it work
so well.
It's gonna be
really, really good.
♪♪